our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning mullah Liang he introduces us to
a reporter who is not scared to ask
those tough questions and make sure
every voice is heard in his community of
Toledo Ohio and he's only 11 years old
mullah lankey good morning good morning
Joe Rika Jayden Jefferson first caught
our eye last month after reporting on a
nurse's strike in his hometown
since then he has gone viral for his
political reporting and Jayden has every
intention of making journalism a career
and it appears he's not waiting to get
started this is the Eyewitness News and
also I guess doubles as your family's
dining room - yeah but we never eat in
here that's the thing Toledo's Jaden
Jefferson is working his own news
operation now if you really want to see
it up close in the mornings it can get
hectic because if I get breaking news I
try to print out that story read over
again then post some stuff social media
write a web story for it so it's a lot a
lot for anyone let alone a self-taught
eleven-year-old multimedia journalist he
writes shoots produces and edits his own
stories the city will file orders for
you to make sure that your grass is cut
yeah it really is just me the weed part
comes in with my grandma she's the
drivers threat to the car he may not
have a news van or a news team but in
Jaden's case that's what family's for
Mom Linnell and dad James are their
son's biggest fans or Jaden's parents
everywhere we go I mean I'm getting
people that work all the time stopping
me said hey you know
that's that's our side when you
interview presidential candidates the
chance of you being squashed my media's
high last month Jaden was shoulder to
shoulder with the national press he
posed the first question two and got an
exclusive with presidential candidate
senator Elizabeth Warren
I still believe this to this day I
wasn't 11-man my camera would not be in
the front what are you doing for equal
opportunities for people of color so
that's a really good question you know
every time I think about economic issues
I stop and say but let's also see how it
intersects with race the next day he sat
with another presidential candidate Ohio
congressman Tim Ryan why did you decide
to join us today well I'm a politician
so I'm gonna try to talk to any reporter
I can find between where I'm going he's
constantly consuming local the national
news broadcasts and studying YouTube
tutorials exactly your average preety
outlook just you know saved my life but
this is the stuff that you that you
really that gets you excited stuff like
outlook and right now I'm just getting
camera mounted to the to the tripod this
fall Jaden will be a 6th grader
I'm serious about what I'm asking I'm
not laughing joking kidding making a
joke
that's me asking a serious question and
getting a serious response Toledo Mayor
Wade caps a cabbage has often found
himself on the receiving end of Jaden's
tough questions you know he first
started showing up at public meetings
and gatherings with his camera in tow
you know I assumed it was some sort of a
class project mayor caps of cabbage says
he sees the value Jaden brings to Toledo
he makes the world a better place I know
it sounds corny but he does in our town
and if we had more people like them I'd
go so far as to say we'd have a we'd
have a better quality journalism a
better understanding effects we might
just have a better world - and that is
one assignment Jaden is always working
what's the importance of journalism as
you see it why well you know what why
why does media have a
important role in our country i'ma say
this really clear it makes your life
easier and helps you stay informed and
keeps you safe well I'm happy to say
after a pretty brutal travel schedule
last night right about 1213 hours just
to get to New York Jaden is here with us
in studio he's working on about two
hours of sleep guys we're gonna take it
a little easy enjoy
Claudia I'm sorry Cassandra got here and
I producer enjoyed telling his story so
much because of Jaden's passion for
journalism he's contagious and it's for
all the right reasons it's not to be
seen or to be on TV it's to get to the
truth to get to the facts and to be
anybody you like take him out and city
council meetings is that for real
but why Jaden what was it what sparked
this interest in this need to do it
my love for writing my my tech savviness
really it came together for me writing
is something I always loved doing in
school always something I loved doing
outside of school so these are really
things that I love doing that I wanted
to bring into a career
Jaden how did you get those press
credentials you know politicians well I
think it was probably I mean I'd love to
make connections so when you make good
connections you know there'll be good
people out there that really want to
help you on your way so I think that's
really what helped me get those
credentials what are your favorite types
of stories politics I love politics why
why do you love politics because
politics is an exciting thing we're
talking about here this affects us all
and I mean there's 22 Democratic
candidates and that's really something
interesting in the copper yeah shout out
to shout out to everybody needs a good
support team you've got a really good
support team she's white I know you're
watching right now so my grandma your
parents your folks are in the green room
that's that's the news team that you've
taken over the dining table which they
seem to have allowed oh yeah Jaden
what's the next step then I mean you're
doing this you're putting stories out
there what do you see what is the next
step I think my next step really is I
mean I'm really working to get some
really high up there opportunities some
good things maybe get a possible kind of
internship type of thing I know more
than a lot of interns do all right look
who's coming for our jobs okay Abby I
had no the child labor law say that on
that note stay right there
Jaden Jefferson is not going anywhere
because he's gonna share his own report
on the nation's first underwater
memorial for veterans maybe auditioning
for a job right here that's gonna be our
before we go you're watching CBS this
morning
[Music]